This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A few months ago, I got an intriguing email from the Clinton Foundation. It said that former President Bill Clinton had read the book I co-authored with Kurt Colstad, the 99% Invisible City, and he really enjoyed it, and wanted to interview me for his podcast. I was gobsmacked by all this, and I don't think it really sunk in what was happening until I was face to face with President Clinton on a Zoom where we talked for two hours about cities, design, and my favorite park in North
这里是“99%看不见”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。几个月前，我收到了克林顿基金会发来的一封耐人寻味的邮件。信上说，前总统比尔·克林顿读了我与库尔特·科尔斯特德合著的书《99%看不见的城市》，他非常喜欢这本书，并想在他的播客上采访我。这一切让我惊掉下巴，直到我和克林顿总统面对面进行了一次Zoom视频连线，我们聊了两个小时关于城市、设计以及我最喜欢的位于北
of Lerogark and saw that my grandma used to bring me to as a kid. It's called the Old Mill. That little tidbit didn't make it into the final episode, but we had a great conversation and it was really fun. And so this week, while I happened to be in New York for the Clinton Global Initiative hosting conversations about cities and inclusive design, I thought I'd played this episode that Clinton and I recorded together for his show Why Am I Telling You This?
勒罗加克（Lerogark）的一个公园——我小时候我奶奶经常带我去那里。它被称为老磨坊。那个小花絮没有进入最终的播客正片，但我们的交谈非常愉快，真的很有意思。所以本周，当碰巧在纽约参加克林顿全球倡议大会（Clinton Global Initiative），主持关于城市和包容性设计的对话时，我想我应该播放这集我和克林顿为他的节目《我为什么要告诉你这些？》（Why Am I Telling You This?）共同录制的节目。
So here I am being interviewed by President Bill Clinton. One of the most important and non-political political books I've read in the last decade or more is the social conquest of Earth by the great biologist, E.O. Wilson, who passed away last year at the age of 92. In it, Wilson argues that the most successful species that have ever inhabit in our planet are ants, termites, bees, and people. Because they, out of all those species that have ever existed, have been able to repeatedly avoid opportunities to destroy themselves avoid opportunities to destroy themselves or be destroyed by others. And the one thing they all have in common is that they all have very high levels of cooperation. But of all species, Wilson says humans are the greatest cooperators because their consciousness enables them to evolve in advance
所以，现在我正在接受比尔·克林顿总统的采访。在过去十年甚至更长时间里，我读过的最重要的、非政治性的政治书籍之一，是伟大的生物学家E·O·威尔逊（E.O. Wilson）写的《对地球的社会征服》（The Social Conquest of Earth），他去年以92岁的高龄去世了。在书中，威尔逊认为，曾经在我们的星球上居住过的最成功的物种是蚂蚁、白蚁、蜜蜂和人类。因为在曾经存在过的所有物种中，只有它们能够一次次地避免毁灭自己的机会，避免毁灭自己的机会，或者被别人毁灭。它们共同的一点是，它们都具有极高的合作水平。但在所有物种中，威尔逊说人类是最大的合作者，因为他们的意识使他们能够提前进化，
and their conscience pulls them back from self-destructive behavior before it's too late. So why am I telling you this? Because in an age that seems so dominated by a conflict, it's important that we step back and remind ourselves of our amazing capacity to work together. There's perhaps no greater example of that than the modern city. From the smallest details to the large-scale infrastructure, every piece of the city was thought about, designed, and built by someone to make one large living thing we could all and have it together. When it all works well, it enables our society to work well too. My guest today spends his career chronically these bits of human ingenuity that we so often take for granted.
而他们的良知在为时已晚之前把他们从自我毁灭的行为中拉了回来。所以，我为什么要告诉你这些？因为在一个似乎被冲突主导的时代，退一步并提醒自己拥有惊人的合作能力是很重要的。也许没有比现代城市更伟大的例证了。从最微小的细节到大规模的基础设施，城市的每一个部分都是由某人思考、设计和建造的，旨在创造一个我们可以共同生活和拥有的巨大生命体。当这一切运作良好时，我们的社会也能运作良好。我今天的嘉宾毕生都在记录人类这些我们常常认为理所当然的聪明才智。
Things like the utility codes, the curb cuts, the traffic signals, and much more. Roman Mars is the host of the 99% Invisible Podcast and co-author of the 99% Invisible City. His work challenges all of us to look up, look around and think about the how and the why of design. Roman, thanks so much for being here. Oh, my pleasure, Mr. President. Thank you so much. And thanks for writing that book. It was, it's really, really good. I had so much fun with it.
诸如公用事业规范、路缘坡道、交通信号灯等等。罗曼·马尔斯是“99%看不见”播客的主持人，也是《99%看不见的城市》的合著者。他的工作挑战着我们所有人去抬头、环顾四周，并思考设计的“如何”与“为什么”。罗曼，非常感谢你能来。哦，我的荣幸，总统先生。非常感谢。也谢谢你写了那本书。它真的很棒，真的非常好。我读得津津有味。
I appreciate it. My colleague, Kurt Colstead and I put it together as we were doing the show. And it was probably one of the hardest things that we've ever done. But it was, it was really gratifying in the end. I appreciate you, you've written it. Was there one specific thing that kind of got you started on this whole idea of 99% invisible and how you came to focus on it? Well, I was in radio for a long time. I just love the way explaining things on the radio.
我很感激。我的同事库尔特·科尔斯特德和我是在做节目的过程中把它整理出来的。这可能是我们做过的最艰难的事情之一。但最终它确实非常令人欣慰。我很感激你写了它。有没有什么具体的事情让你开始了关于“99%看不见”的整个想法，以及你是如何开始关注它的？嗯，我在广播界待了很久。我就是喜欢在广播里解释事物的方式。
I love the way people talk on public radio in particular. And I also was just a person who went on architecture tours. And so I've noticed a training, and I was trained to be a scientist actually. And there was one building that was the Chicago Architecture Foundation has a boat tour in Chicago that talks about the architecture. It's amazing.
我特别喜欢人们在公共广播里说话的方式。而且我恰好也是一个会去参加建筑之旅的人。所以我注意到了一种训练，我其实是受过科学家训练的。有一次，芝加哥建筑基金会在芝加哥有一个游船之旅，专门讲解建筑。这太棒了。
I recommend everybody. I've been on it like five or six times. I'm like, I really do love it. And they told this story of the Montgomery Ward complex. That's along the river. And Montgomery Ward is, you know, kind of long gone as a company. But there's this one, the headquarters building was this kind of generic rectangular, modernist building. But they had these four concrete posts on the corner and eyed passes building all the time.
我向所有人推荐。我参加过五六次了。我觉得，我真的是太喜欢了。他们讲述了河边的蒙哥马利·沃德（Montgomery Ward）综合大楼的故事。你知道，蒙哥马利·沃德作为一家公司已经不复存在了。但这里有一个，总部大楼是一种通用的长方形现代主义建筑。但它的拐角处有四根混凝土柱子，我经常路过这座建筑。
I'd never cared much for it. And then the architecture, the curator on the boat, the docent said that, well, the reason why that building is the way it is is that the Montgomery Ward Company sort of pried itself on its egalitarian hierarchy. And they wanted to build their headquarters so that there were no VPs fighting over who got the corner office. And so they made a building with no possibility of a corner office at all. And I just love that story and made me love this building that I thought was boring. It made no impression on me, but then it made me love it. And then I realized, well, if you can tell a story like that, that's independent
我从来没有太在意过它。然后建筑，船上的策展人，也就是讲解员说，好吧，这座建筑之所以是这个样子的原因，是因为蒙哥马利·沃德公司为其平等的等级制度感到自豪。他们希望建造他们的总部，这样就不会有副总裁们争夺谁能得到转角办公室。所以他们建造了一座根本不可能有转角办公室的建筑。我太喜欢这个故事了，它让我爱上了这座我曾经觉得很无聊的建筑。它没有给我留下任何印象，但后来它让我爱上了它。然后我意识到，好吧，如果你能讲这样一个独立于
of the aesthetics and the sort of like image of the building, then I could tell stories about architecture on the radio. And that's where I sort of got the idea that we could do this. All the thought that goes into things that most people don't think about is really tantalizing to the brain. They go, oh yeah, I guess I have always noticed that. And then it begins to build on something. And then they begin to read plaques. And they notice the sidewalk markings of like what the utility lines are underneath the street. And it makes the world just a little bit more delightful once you begin to sort of key into those little markers. I want to talk a little bit about radio as a medium, and I'll come back to what you said. But I remember in 1982, after I had lost in the Reagan landslide in 1980 and become the youngest ex-governor in the history of America, and I was thinking about running again.
建筑美学和所谓建筑形象的故事，那么我就可以在广播里讲述关于建筑的故事。这就是我产生我们可以这样做的想法的地方。人们没有想到的事情背后所包含的所有思考，对大脑来说真的很诱人。他们会说，哦，对啊，我想我一直都注意到了这一点。然后它开始建立起某种东西。然后他们开始阅读牌匾。他们注意到人行道上的标记，比如街道底下的公用管线是什么。一旦你开始关注这些小标记，世界就会变得稍微更加令人愉快一点。我想聊聊广播作为一种媒介，然后我会回到你刚才说的话。但我记得在1982年，在1980年里根压倒性胜选（Reagan landslide）中落败、成为美国历史上最年轻的前州长之后，我在考虑是否要再次竞选。
And it's all the poll show that I had a chance to win, but we had never had a governor elected, defeated and elected again. And it's all the polls show that I had a chance to win, but we had never had a governor elected defeated and elected again. And I read a book by a New York media guy named Tony Schwartz. He had this theory that if done well, radio would be more compelling than television because it had more power over the imagination. Yeah. And I'll never forget, I talked to him, I bet for two hours about it one night. And for the next several years, I invested a lot of time, money, and effort
所有的民调都显示我有机会获胜，但我们从来没有过一位州长在落败后再次当选的先例。而且所有的民调都显示我有机会获胜，但我们从来没有过一位州长在落败后再次当选的先例。我读了一本由纽约媒体人托尼·施瓦茨（Tony Schwartz）写书。他有一个理论，如果做得好，广播比电视更有吸引力，因为它对想象力的掌控力更强。是的。我永远不会忘记，有一天晚上我跟他就这个聊了足足有两个小时。在接下来的几年里，我投入了大量的时间、金钱和精力
in radio communications and trying to imagine what would trigger an open mind. He also said, you know, if somebody's been against you on the other side of something, it's harder for them to look at you than it is to listen to you. So he said, you know, if somebody just kind of comes along and they talk and they say, halfway decent, you know,
在无线电通信上，并试图想象什么能触发一个开放的心态。他还说，你知道，如果有人在某事的另一边反对你，他们看你比听你说话要难。所以他说，你知道，如果有人走过来，他们说话，他们说的话还算半个正派，你知道，
and you're not losing face by listening, even if you've been calling them names for years. I love that. Tony Schwartz is super fascinating as a human. I'm so like envious that you got to meet him. I love the sound of people's voices. I'm sort of hooklining sinker like for radio all the time. There's people talk about having radio voices and I love all voices. I love the tone of people's voices.
而且你听了也不会丢面子，哪怕你已经骂了他们好几年。我太喜欢了。托尼·施瓦茨作为一个人超级迷人。我太嫉妒你能见到他了。我喜欢人们的声音。我总是对广播毫无保留地着迷。有人说他们有广播腔，我喜欢所有的声音。我喜欢人们说话的语调。
I love what it conveys. There's just something about storytelling in this way that has always sort of made my brain light up. I don't know what it is. You've done all these episodes about things that we've all seen but not seen. Things that are obscure or at least rare like the only street light with green on the top instead of the bottom and Syracuse. But of all the things you've written about and I again if for any of our listeners who've not listened to your podcasts or read your book about the 99% invisible world. What are two or three of your favorite stories, insights, things that you just were interested in and you got involved in them and it surprised you what you learned? Well, one of the first things I did a story about that I thought about a lot were actually municipal and city and state flags.
我喜欢它传达的内容。以这种方式讲述故事，总能让我的大脑兴奋起来，这其中有些奇妙之处。我不知道为什么。你做了所有这些关于我们都见过但又没真正看过的东西的节目。那些晦涩难懂或至少很罕见的节目，比如雪城那个顶部是绿色而不是底部的唯一红绿灯。但在你写过的所有事情中——我想再次对那些没有听过你的播客或读过关于99%看不见的世界的书的听众说——你最喜欢的两三个故事、见解或事情是什么？你只是对它们感兴趣并参与其中，而你学到的东西让你大吃一惊？嗯，我最早做的故事之一，也是我想了很多的，其实是市政、城市和州的旗帜。
I really love flags. I really love flags, I really love graphic design, and I worked in Chicago at a radio station there called WBZ. And when you're in Chicago, all of a sudden you notice that there's the flag of Chicago because it is everywhere. And if you really go to almost any other city, you never see the flag of a city as much as you see the city of Chicago flag. And I didn't even know cities had flags before I moved to Chicago. And then I began to sort of look at them and realize that like basically every city
我真的很喜欢旗帜。我真的超级喜欢旗帜，我非常喜欢平面设计，我曾在芝加哥的一家名为WBZ的广播电台工作。当你在芝加哥时，你会突然注意到芝加哥的旗帜，因为它无处不在。如果你去几乎任何其他城市，你永远不会像看到芝加哥市旗那样频繁地看到一个城市的旗帜。在我搬到芝加哥之前，我甚至不知道城市还有旗帜。然后我开始审视它们，并意识到像基本上每个
over 50,000 people has a flag. They're just not really well designed. They're kind of an afterthought and no one notices them. And so I began to really like think about the design of flags and what you can do with them. And that was the one that really sort of like kind of took off. I even did a Ted talk about city flags at a certain point. And it was a really kind of crazy moment where Ted conference starts all these extremely important people like yourself presenting. I'm about to do my little flag talk. I've held it so sort of silly, but it really resonated with people because my contention was,
人口超过5万的城市都有一面旗帜。它们只是设计得不怎么好。它们有点像马后炮，没有人会去注意它们。所以我开始真正思考旗帜的设计以及你能用它们做什么。那是真正腾飞的一个。甚至在某个时候，我还做了一个关于城市旗帜的TED演讲。那是一个非常疯狂的时刻，TED大会上所有这些极其重要的人（比如你）都在发表演讲。我正准备做我的小旗帜演讲。我一直觉得这有点傻，但它确实引起了人们的共鸣，因为我的论点是，
was that the reason why Chicago's flag was so used was because it was so beautiful and so well done. And if people don't know it, it has a white field, it has two horizontal blue stripes and four, six pointed red stars across the center. And you will see it like on cops uniforms. You will see it on municipal buildings. But you also see it on like punk rockers tattoos like everyone has claimed it. And it wasn't just that, you know, people love Chicago who live there and therefore love the flag. I also think that people loved Chicago more because the flag was so cool and the power of that type of graphic design to unify people for like somebody who you know represented the city to use it for someone protesting the city to use it these municipal symbols that weren't owned by anyone that were owned by all of us was really like
芝加哥的旗帜之所以被广泛使用，是因为它太漂亮了，做得太好了。如果人们不知道它长什么样，它有一个白色的底面，有两条水平的蓝色条纹，中心有四颗六角红星。你会看到它印在警察的制服上。你会看到它出现在市政建筑上。但你也会看到它印在朋克摇滚乐手的纹身上——每个人都认领了它。不仅是因为生活在那里的人热爱芝加哥，因而热爱这面旗帜。我还认为，人们更加热爱芝加哥是因为这面旗帜太酷了，这种平面设计能够将人们凝聚在一起的力量——对于代表城市的人可以使用它，对于抗议城市的人也可以使用它——这些不属于任何人、属于我们所有人的市政符号，真的让我觉得
Inspiring to me and so then I think other ones, you know, like I think that, you know, the one of the first stories I ever did was about the Trans-American Pyramid. I'm located in the Bay Area. I see it every day out my window. It is very striking. And one of the things that I had learned, which was kind of like the impetus for the whole show, was that the local chapter of the American Institute of Architects truly opposed this building when it was built. They thought it was sort of a height of modernism.
很受启发。所以我想其他的，你知道，比如，你知道我做过的最早的故事之一是关于泛美金字塔（Transamerica Pyramid）。我住在湾区。我每天都能从窗户看到它。它非常引人注目。我学到的一件事——这也是整个节目的契机——是美国建筑师协会（American Institute of Architects）当地分会在该建筑建造时坚决反对它。他们认为这是现代主义的巅峰之作。
So like the pyramid, to make the pyramid shape, the top 200 feet of the building is kind of empty glass. Like it has no real purpose. And modernism is all about, you know, like, unadorned, like functional forms, like no extra anything. And it was like offensive to modernists that there would be this like 200 feet of air that did nothing except for a complete
比如金字塔，为了形成金字塔的形状，建筑顶部200英尺是某种空旷的玻璃空间。就好像它没有什么真正的用途。而现代主义完全讲究的是没有多余装饰的、功能性的形式，不需要任何多余的东西。让现代主义者感到被冒犯的是，居然有这200英尺的空气除了完成
a shape of a pyramid. And they posed it and they talked poorly about it. But, you know, like in the sort of many decades since, it'd become, you know, this thing that everyone loved and it's identified with San Francisco. It wasn't so much like whether or not the building was beautiful, or ugly, or worked, or didn't work, or violated this principle, whatever, what I'm interested in is what are the values
金字塔的形状之外什么都不做。他们反对它，并对它恶语相向。但是，你知道，在过去的几十年里，它已经变成了每个人都喜爱的东西，并且成为了旧金山的标志。这不仅仅关乎这座建筑是漂亮、是丑、是实用、是不实用，还是违反了什么原则，我感兴趣的是我们建造的东西的
of the things that we build? And what does it say about us? how does it change over time, the effective things? It's the human activity that centers around these objects. That is really what the show is about in my interest. I've read some interesting fiction actually about San Francisco more than 100 years ago on about the Earthquake and what happened during the earthquake, what happened after the earthquake. Is there anything that stands out to you about how after the earthquake building standards or neighborhood organizations were changed in a way that made life
价值是什么？它说明了什么？事物的成效是如何随时间改变的？围绕这些对象展开的人类活动，才真正是这个节目的核心以及我的兴趣所在。其实我读过一些关于100多年前旧金山的小说，关于地震以及地震期间发生的事情、地震之后发生的事情。对于地震后建筑标准或邻里组织是如何改变的，从而使生活
at least somewhat more secure? Yeah, I mean, you know, the founding of most cities can be pretty half-hazard. You know, they begin people plot out land. There usually isn't a grand design and grand plan. And then disasters like the Chicago Fire and the 1906 earthquake give people a chance to like really start with a plan now that they've seen that the city is there and is robust, and there's a need for it. It sees like Chicago and Paris,
变得至少在某种程度上更有保障，有没有什么让你印象深刻的地方？是的，我的意思是，你知道，大多数城市的建立可以说是相当随意的。你知道，它们开始时人们规划土地。通常没有宏大的设计和宏大的计划。然后像芝加哥大火和1906年地震这样的灾难，让人们有机会真正从一个计划开始，既然他们已经看到城市就在那里并且很强韧，而且有这种需求。像芝加哥和巴黎这样的城市，
who went through really strong, sort of heavy-handed, design, have a certain style. And what I think is interesting about cities is when you have these moments of evolution and what we grab onto and what we build off of them, really reflects the moment in time and then you sort of go from there. And when I was, I mean, not to sort of equate these
它们经历了非常强烈、有些简单粗暴的设计，有一种特定的风格。我认为城市有趣的地方在于，当你经历这些演变时刻时，我们所抓住的以及我们在其基础上建造的东西，真正反映了当下的时代，然后你就可以从那里继续前进。当我，我是说，并不是一定要把这些
disasters necessarily, but like, I was really struck. The book came out right when the beginning of COVID shutdown started. And all of a sudden, this ingenuity of the built space, cropped up overnight so that people could still function. So there were plexiglass showed up in front of Bodega cash registers and little markings on the floor to tell us where to stand. And sidewalks began places for us to sit and congregate
灾难相提并论，但是，我真的很震惊。这本书出版的时候，正好赶上新冠疫情封锁开始的时候。突然之间，建筑空间的这种独创性在一夜之间涌现出来，好让人们依然能够运转。因此，杂货店收银台前出现了有机玻璃，地板上出现了告诉我们站在哪里的地标。人行道开始成为我们坐下来聚集的地方，
when they used to just be the domain, or even into the roads. That used to just be the domain of roads. No one took away a road from anybody, but all of a sudden you could form a cafe and people accepted that. And the thing that I love about thinking about cities is that when you're in them, there's a habit of thinking, this thing is the way it is.
而它们过去只是，甚至延伸到马路上。过去马路仅仅是马路的领域。没有人从任何人手里夺走一条路，但突然之间你可以开一家咖啡馆，人们接受了这一点。关于思考城市，我最喜欢的一点是，当你在城市中时，有一种习惯思维，认为这个东西就是这个样子的。
It was this way when I was born into this world and noticed it, and it's very hard to change. But they've always been these evolving entities that reflected our values. And I like noticing that because I think that that's important to considering change in a place. Like if you don't think a thing is fixed and it is a way that it's supposed to be, then all the sudden the possibilities of what you can do with a road opens up. Because like roads started for like millennia, they were like multi-purpose, multi-modal, like people walked across them, vendors would sit on them, cars would be on them, horses would be on them, trolley lines would be on them, and all of a sudden for about a hundred
当我出生并注意到这个世界时，它就是这个样子的，而且它很难改变。但它们一直都是这些不断演变的实体，反映了我们的价值观。我喜欢注意到这一点，因为我认为这对于考虑某个地方的变化很重要。如果你不认为某样东西是固定不变的、它本来就该是那个样子的，那么突然之间，你对一条路能做什么的可能性就打开了。因为就像道路开始时持续了数千年一样，它们是多用途的、多式联运的——人们走过它们，小贩坐在上面，汽车在上面，马匹在上面，有轨电车线路在上面——而突然之间，大约一百
years we just gave away roads to just cars, cars meant roads. And then we went through this period of crisis with COVID where all of a sudden we were like, well, maybe a car is the most important thing in this spot right now, maybe a cafe sitting area is the most important thing. And it kind of dislodges us to think about the possibilities that these built structures that seem so permanent and so fixed are really malleable reflections of our values. And they can always be reable reflections of our values and they can always be re-examined and they can always have input and change because of them. And there was moments of crisis kind of shock us into thinking of how we can change something
年的时间里，我们只是把道路拱手让给汽车，汽车就等于道路。然后我们经历了一场新冠疫情危机，突然之间我们觉得，好吧，也许在这个地方，汽车现在不是最重要的东西，也许咖啡馆的露天座位区才是最重要的。这让我们打破了固有思维，去思考这些看似如此永久、如此固定的建筑结构，其实是我们价值观的灵活反映。它们始终可以成为我们价值观的灵活反映，它们总是可以被重新审视，并且总是可以因为它们而拥有投入和改变。危机的时刻会震撼我们，让我们思考如何将某些事情变得更好
for the better. When for most of our lives, most of our existence, these seem like completely intractable, unplacable, unchangeable forces because they're hard physical surfaces, but they really can't change. And that's what I find inspiring about thinking about those moments in our history and what we can make and do. We'll be right back. One of the things that interests me is that shows the malleability of cities, but also the importance of basic functions being modified and improved,
。而在我们生命的大部分时间里、我们存在的大部分时间里，这些看起来像是完全无法解决的、不可取代的、不可改变的力量，因为它们是坚硬的物理表面，但它们确实可以改变。这就是我在思考我们历史上的那些时刻以及我们能创造和做到什么时感到鼓舞的地方。我们马上回来。让我感兴趣的事情之一是，这展示了城市的适应性，以及修改和改进基本功能的重要性，
is how cities respond to things that they hadn't imagined happening. For example, Stephen Johnson's book, The Ghost Map, is about the discovery of the real cause of the cholera outbreak in London. And it led to a total rework of how the water came to the city and how it was purified. One of the things that I was hoping would come when I was going through your book I was hoping would come out of it is that people would copy Things that work that they hadn't thought about and adapted to their own culture of taste and environment Yeah
即城市如何应对他们没有想到的事情。例如，史蒂芬·约翰逊（Stephen Johnson）的书《幽灵地图》（The Ghost Map），讲的是发现伦敦霍乱爆发的真正原因。它导致了城市供水方式和净化方式的彻底重组。我希望从你的书里看到的一点——当我读你的书时，我希望看到的一点——是人们会去效仿那些他们没有想过但管用的事情，并使之适应他们自己的文化、品味和环境。是的。
Well, it does happen. So there's like a the book is sort of laid out You know, we sort of get There's like a, the book is sort of laid out, you know, where we sort of get granular and then we get, like bigger, bigger views, you know, from, of the world. And it ends with this section on urbanism that is all about the conversation between, sort of top down forces who shape the world and bottom up forces that affect the city.
嗯，确实会发生。所以这本书的布局是这样的，你知道，我们首先探讨，这本书的布局是这样的，你知道，我们从细微处着手，然后我们得到更大、更广阔的视角，你知道，从世界的角度。它以关于城市主义的一个章节结束，该章节完全关乎塑造世界的自上而下的力量与影响城市的自下而上的力量之间的对话。
And that conversation that happens between, you know, people who give like urban interventions or design solutions, like you mentioned, like local ones, and then I think of really mindful government or bigger entity, notices those things, takes those ideas, adapts them, because there's certain types of things that we have built our society on that only government can do, you know, bridges and highways. And those are amazing things. I think I take sort of almost spiritual solace in these things. Like I look at the Golden Gate Bridge and I just think it is the greatest structure that was ever created. And it represents all these people getting together to do a thing where a bunch of people recognize, you know, it'd be
而这种对话发生在以下两者之间：那些提供城市干预或设计解决方案的人（比如你提到的那些本地解决方案），然后我认为一个真正有思想的政府或更大的实体，会注意到这些事情，吸纳这些ideas，并使之适应，因为我们建立社会所依据的某些类型的事情只有政府才能做到，（你知道，桥梁和高速公路）。这些都是了不起的事情。我想我对这些事情有着近乎精神上的慰藉。比如我看着金门大桥，我只是认为它是曾经创造过的最伟大的结构。它代表了所有人聚在一起做一件事，在这里许多人认识到，（你知道，）
really good for all these people over here to be able to get to the side over here. And then we're going to spend, you know, like 10 years making that happen and also create something like gorgeous in the process. And that collective enterprise is government and it's meaningful to me. But there are things that are great to do in a place in a moment, solve a problem, affect a change, that is just as sort of inspiring and powerful. And I love those things. I mean, some of them are like, you know, there can be interventions like there was a sort of a prankster basically, like,
让这里的所有人能够到达那边将会是一件非常棒的事情。然后我们要花上，（你知道，比如）10年的时间来实现这一点，并在过程中创造出如此宏伟的东西。这种集体企业就是政府，它对我有意义。但有些事情在某个地方的某个时刻去做是很棒的，能解决一个问题，带来改变，这同样鼓舞人心且充满力量。我喜欢这些事情。我的意思是，其中一些就像，（你知道，）可能会有一些干预措施，就像有一个恶作剧者一样，基本上，
who noticed on, he drove drove in a lay, he noticed he always missed an exit on the five because it wasn't labeled properly. And so, like, he literally made a fake highway sign, went up at 6am with his friends, made it as real as possible, bolted it up, and had this sign that was there to mark and exit that he thought was undermarked. So he would always miss it. And it was so convincing that it stayed up for like a decade because nobody noticed it was a fake.
他注意到，他开车行驶在一条车道上，他发现自己总是错过5号公路的一个出口，因为它没有正确标示。所以，他真的制作了一个假的公路标志，早上6点和他的朋友一起去，把它做得尽可能逼真，用螺栓固定好，立起了这个标志，用来标示他认为标示不清的一个出口。这样他就不会总是错过了。它是如此具有说服力，以至于它挂了大约十年，因为没有人注意到它是假的。
And it was this, I do not recommend anyone doing this. It was super dangerous. But the point is, there's always these little moments to improve and do something to make the world better that are worth working on, and they don't have to be something like the Golden Gate Bridge. They don't have to be an entire sewer system that requires buy-in from every community down the line and hundreds of millions of dollars. You really can't affect change in these smaller areas to just make a little bit better,
这是一个，我不建议任何人这样做。这超级危险。但重点是，总会有这些小小的时刻去改进并做一些让世界变得更好的事情，这些是值得努力去做的，它们不必像金门大桥那样。它们不必是一个需要沿线每个社区的支持以及数亿美元的整个下水道系统。你确实可以在这些较小的领域产生改变，让事情变得稍微好一点，
like little pocket parks, little seed bombs or something that people like, in an empty lot, they'll take flowering plants and just like throw them in and just like make something. That's what makes the city. First I agree with that. I got several things going to ask you, but I would like to start with design and aid of public safety. The very first specific example I believe in your book, if my memory serves, is about steel poles that are really two poles where you have to build something that, well, either hold a building up or hold a sign up or hold a whatever up and you have to dig down deep.
比如微型口袋公园，或者人们在一块空地上拿花卉植物随手一撒，就能创造出一些东西。这就是城市之所以成为城市的原因。首先我同意这一点。我有几个问题要问你，但我想从设计对公共安全的帮助开始。据我记忆所知，你书中的第一个具体例子是关于钢柱的，它们实际上是两根柱子，你必须建造一些东西，要么撑起一栋建筑，要么撑起一个标志，或者撑起其他什么东西，你必须往下挖得很深。
So you have to have a long sturdy pole to hold the weight. But instead, safety designers actually made them double poles and they bolted them together somewhere near ground level with screws that guaranteed or bolst enough flexibility so that if a car ran into them or something else hard hit them, they would actually break. Yeah. So how did that come about? How did engineers think about that? How many people had to die before they figured it out? Well, I'm sure way too many, but you know, breakaway posts, you're talking about a pole
所以你必须有一根长而坚固的柱子来承重。但相反，安全设计人员实际上将它们做成了双柱，并在接近地面的某个地方用螺丝将它们螺栓连接起来，这些螺丝保证了足够的灵活性，这样如果一辆车撞上它们或其他坚硬的东西撞击它们，它们实际上会断裂。是的。那么这是怎么做出来的？工程师们是如何思考这个问题的？有多少人为此付出了生命，他们才琢磨明白？嗯，我敢肯定太多了，但是，你知道，可折断的柱子，你谈论的是一根柱子，
that is an environment like right next to where cars are speeding past. I mean, it has to do two different jobs simultaneously. It has to be robust enough to hold up this heavy thing that is the sign or the wires. And it has to just do the complete opposite thing. Like, it has to completely try to get out of the way as fast and as easily as possible if somebody runs into it. So yeah, you're right. They have these connector plates and breakaway bolts. Sometimes even those connector plates are angled so that if you hit them at the right angle, not only does the pole like fall over, it kind of like vaults over the vehicle and doesn't hit it at all.
它所处的环境就在汽车呼啸而过的旁边。我的意思是，它必须同时做两件不同的工作。它必须足够坚固，以支撑这个作为标志或电线的沉重物体。它还必须做完全相反的事情。比如，如果有人撞上它，它必须以最快、最轻松的方式尽快避开。所以是的，你是对的。它们有连接板和可断裂螺栓。有时甚至这些连接板都是有角度的，如果你以正确的角度撞击它们，不仅柱子会倒下，它还会有点像在车辆上方腾空翻越，根本不会撞到它。
And then, you know, like if you need to replace it, the base post is still there. It hasn't been damaged, you just bolt on a new one and then you also have that aspect of safety, like you can return to normal faster. I do not know how many people had to run into a post for this to change or all the people that were involved. I mean, I'm sure that there were hundreds of different engineers involved, but they're like, it is one of those invisible design elements that is that you would never
然后，你知道，如果需要更换它，底座柱子还在。它没有被损坏，你只需用螺栓装上一个新的，然后你也有了安全方面的优势，你可以更快地恢复正常。我不知道有多少人不得不撞上柱子才能促成这种改变，或者涉及了多少人。我的意思是，我敢肯定有数百名不同的工程师参与其中，但它们就像是，它是那些你永远不会注意到的隐形设计元素之一，
notice, like unless you're really paying attention to posts and you notice the throw breakaway play, it is not there to be honored or paid attention to. It is actually not even there to be used, hopefully. It is there just in case to make the world a little bit better place, a little bit safer place. And what would I like to do in the show and in the book is have people notice those things so that they are aware of all the design decisions that are made around them to make their life a little bit better because it is
除非你真的在关注柱子并注意到可断裂的连接板，否则它不是为了受到赞誉或被关注而存在的。它甚至根本不是为了被使用而存在的（希望如此）。它存在只是以防万一，让世界变得更好一点，更安全一点。而我在节目和书中想做的是让人们注意到这些事情，这样他们就能意识到周围为使他们的生活变得更好而做出的所有设计决策，因为
really easy to not see these things and really think that you're on your own in the world. But you're not. You know, there's a bunch of people that thought about a problem that you've never even thought about and solved it before you even had to encounter it. And it makes the world more clearly reflect that we are like interconnected group of people that are trying to create a place where we can all live and thrive. And those breakaway bolts are a great example of this. Like most people never notice them, most people never encounter them. They are everywhere,
真的很不容易看到这些事情，并且真的会认为在这个世界上你是孤身一人的。但你并不是。你知道，有一群人思考了一个你从未想过的问题，并在你不得不遇到它之前就解决了它。这更清楚地反映出我们是一个相互关联的人群，正试图创造一个我们都能生活和繁荣的地方。而那些可断裂的螺栓就是一个很好的例子。大多数人从未注意到它们，大多数人从未遇到过它们。它们无处不在，
and they're just there, just in case, so that you're safer, that you're more important than the sign is. And I love those examples. I find those examples like super inspiring, and those design solutions are everywhere if you just know how to look for them. It's fascinating. I was going to ask you about another sort of related thing to me.
它们就在那里，以防万一，为了让你更安全，为了让你比那个标志更重要。我喜欢这些例子。我发现这些例子超级鼓舞人心，只要你知道如何去寻找，这些设计解决方案无处不在。这太迷人了。我本来想问你另一个与之相关的事情。
To me, it's related. And that's how design happens in the first place. And why some people in some societies thought about things that others didn't, even if they had common levels of income and capacity. About half my lifetime ago, I don't know, 35, 40 years ago, a woman that I knew well when we were very young and she came from a town even smaller than Hope, Arkansas, and my native state, went to New York, became interested in, you know, the origins of humanity and went to Africa to study with the Lakers, with Richard Lakers. She wrote a book called The Hominate Game and then it was about all the people that were
对我来说，这是相关的。那就是设计是如何首先发生的。为什么某些社会中的一些人会思考其他人没有想过的事情，即使他们拥有相当的收入和能力水平。大约在我生命的一半前，我不知道，35、40年前，我认识的一个女人，在我们很年轻的时候，她来自一个甚至比阿肯色州霍普（Hope）还要小的城镇（霍普是我出生并长大的家乡），她去了纽约，对人类的起源产生了兴趣，并去了非洲与勒基（Laker）家族一起学习，和理查德·勒基（Richard Laker）在一起。她写了一本书叫《人属游戏》（The Hominate Game），讲的是所有那些
digging up our ancestors' history. And she got very interested in the design of prehistoric civilizations. So she did another book, which I went back while I was getting ready for this and I looked at it again, I had looked at it in so many years called the Sand Dollar and the Slider Rule, or name is Delta Willis, and this book is about how patterns of nature are reflected in human construction and have always been. are reflected in human construction and have always been. So I thought I would ask you about that. How much do you believe in general that a lot of the things we do basically evolve from what we perceive to be happening in nature? Well, I don't know if a good answer to this.
发掘我们祖先历史的人。她对史前文明的设计产生了浓厚的兴趣。所以她写了另一本书——我在为这次采访做准备时回去翻看了一下，我已经很多年没看过它了——叫做《沙元与计算尺》（The Sand Dollar and the Slider Rule），作者名叫德尔塔·威利斯（Delta Willis）。这本书讲的是大自然中的模式是如何反映在人类建筑中的，并且一直以来都是如此。所以我认为我可以问你关于这个的问题。你总体上有多少相信，我们做的很多事情基本上是从我们认为正在自然界中发生的事情演变而来的？嗯，我不知道这算不算一个好的回答。
Maybe it's a stupid question. No, I don't think it's a stupid question at all. It's just sort of hard to answer because I'm sure the sort of stew of things that gives us thought and solutions has to be what's around us. Nothing sort of like spontaneously generates. And so what I find kind of inspiring about humanity is when we go beyond our empirical senses to study and evolve. I think that when we, when we're looking for ideas, you should always look for nature to like how it was solved, how it solved well, and try to harness it, and then go crazy on like everything else
也许这是一个愚蠢的问题。不，我一点也不觉得这是一个愚蠢的问题。这只是很难回答，因为我确信给我们思想和解决方案的各种事物的“大杂烩”一定是我们周围的东西。没有什么东西是自发产生的。因此，关于人性，让我觉得有些启发的是，当我们超越经验感官去学习和进化时。我认为，当我们寻找创意时，你应该始终向自然界寻找它是如何解决问题的，它是如何很好地解决的，并试着利用它，然后在所有其他你可能做的事情上疯狂发挥，那些与自然无关的事情。但我确实发现，最鼓舞人心的事物之一——我发现很多好的设计都是——是自然的循环、非提取部分、可持续的（你知道，这就是我们所说的可持续）。它的行为就像地球一样是可持续的。我希望人们在设计事物时能一直坚持这一点。它们应该模仿生态系统。生态系统是一个非常完美平衡的事物。运作良好的城市就像生态系统一样运转。
that you could possibly do that has nothing to do with nature. But I do find that like one of the things that is most inspiring and I find that a lot of good design is the cyclical, non-extractive part of nature, the sustainable, you know, that's what we mean by sustainable. It's like kind of behaves like the earth is like sustainable. And that I hope people always stick to when it comes to like designing things. They should mimic an ecosystem. And ecosystem is a really perfectly balanced thing. And cities that work well function as ecosystems.
我的意思是，它们必须有这些高大、坚固的大型结构，构成了事物的基础，这样我们才能聚集在大型场所，它们有锚点。然后我们有稍微更短暂一点的建筑片段，在某种交通方式流行然后改变的时期满足我们的需求。这些必须更具灵活性，必须被拆除。但这些骨架非常重要。当我想象一个我爱的城市时，我非常喜欢匹兹堡作为一座城市。维持它作为一个地方的一点是，卡耐基为各种事物建造了所有这些宫殿。
I mean, they have to have these tall, like firm big structures that sort of form the basis of things, you know, so that we can gather in big places and they have anchors. And then we have like slightly more ephemeral bits of architecture that serve our needs for periods of time when a mode of transportation is in fashion and then changes. Those have to be more flexible, have to be torn down. But those bones are really important. When I think about a city I love, I love Pittsburgh as a city. One of the things that sustained it as a place was that Carnegie built all these palaces
当这座城市因为钢铁工业的衰退而满目疮痍时，那些东西依然还在。那些公民机构依然还在，这样艺术就可以进来，技术就可以进来。但那些骨架依然存在，就像森林里的树木一样。这种将建造环境构想为一个复杂的生态系统并以这些方式模仿自然的观念，对我们非常有益，因为它在发生变化时使其更具韧性。但当你创造这些东西时，你必须考虑长远的博弈。
to things. When the city was gutted because of the decline in the steel industry, those things were still there. Those civic institutions were still there so that art could come in and technology could come in. But those bones were there that were like the trees in a forest. And that sort of conceiving of the built environment as a complex ecosystem and mimicking nature in these ways, it really behooves us because it makes it more resilient for when there is change. But you have to think of the long game when you're creating these things.
所以我认为有大量的灵感可以从自然、开放以及所有这些不同部分互动的方式中汲取，高度设计的系统有时可以超级高效。但当出现瑕疵时，就会出现真正的问题。比如我的一个例子是，你知道，比如iPhone。这是一件我喜爱的奇妙事物。我喜欢使用它。我喜欢摆弄它。
And so I think there's tons of inspiration to come from nature and openness and the sort of like the way that all these different pieces interact and highly designed systems sometimes can be super efficient. But when there's a flaw, there's a real problem. Like one of my examples is like, you know, like an iPhone. Is this a marvelous thing that I love. I love to use it. I love to mess with it.
这是我播放大部分音乐或听人们声音的方式。但当那个东西不工作时，这就叫坏了。它坏了。没有办法进入它。它无能为力。你必须把它拿给别人修理。就像我从小听着长大的一样。我家里有一台盘式录音机（reel to reel）。如果那个盘式录音机坏了，你
It's the way I play most music or listen to people's voices. But when that thing doesn't work, it's called breaking. It's breaking. There's no way into it. There's nothing to do with it. You have to take it to someone to fix it. Like I grew up listening. There was a reel to reel in my household. If something broke on that real to real, you
还有一点机会对它做点什么。它是开放式设计。它允许你对它做一些事情。我喜欢这些开放的系统，而自然更模仿这些开放式系统。你的车也是如此，你知道的。是的，完全正确。我在汽车行业中长大，间接地，我继父在我出生的那个有6000人口的小镇上有一个小甲壳虫经销商。我记得亨利·J·凯撒（Henry J. Kaiser）——老凯撒——大约30英里外的一家经销商发生了一场火灾。他拿了，我不知道，六七辆车，并在他自己的车库里由他的机械师修理了它们，奖品是，我们可以保留一辆亨利·J，所有的车都被砍掉并掏空了，但我高中时开着它，它有液压刹车。因此，每当气管有一点点裂口时，它们就能维持压力。我不得不降档到一档，然后冲上一档，冲到路缘上。但重点是，我觉得我和那辆车合二为一了，因为我觉得我能修好它。
have a little bit of a chance to do something about it. It is like open design. It is like allows you to do stuff to it. And I like those open systems and nature is more mimics those open systems. The same thing is true of your car, you know. Yeah, exactly. I grew up in the car business that indirectly my stepfather had a little bug dealership in the town where I was born, which had 6,000 people. And I remember there was a fire in a dealership of Henry J. Kiser's, the old Kiser's, about 30 miles away. And he took, I don't know, six or seven of them and had
就像如果我必须自己换机油，我可以做到；如果我必须换轮胎，我可以做到。我可以弄清楚如何让发动机重新运转。我认为，尽管科技有种种奇迹，但我希望我们不会被带得离用我们自己的双手和头脑去做事情太远，因为我认为，至少对我来说，它让我更加了解
him repaired him, especially he couldn't, his own garage with his mechanics and the prize was, we got to keep one of the Henry J's, all cut down and hollowed out, but I drove it in high school and it had hydraulic brakes. So whenever there was the slightest gash in the air tube, they'd maintain the pressure. I'd have to go downshifted in the first degree and run up the first gear and run up on the curb. But the point is, I felt one with that car because I felt like I could fix it.
汽车的设计、内部设计、机械原理。你知道，我经常想到这一点。但重点是，我认为当我读你的书时，我一直在想，你知道，我们美国人，也许全世界的人，也许因为社交媒体或极化或其他什么原因，正在失去大局观和细节观。
Just like if I had to change the oil myself, I could do that if I had to change the tires., if I could do that, if I had to change the tires, I could do that. I could figure out how to make the engine work again. And I think that, I think for all the wonders of technology, I wish we wouldn't be taken so far from being able to do things with our own two hands and mind, because I think at least for me me it made me more aware of the
是的，你知道，我们只是想给我们一些我们能在六秒或八秒内消化的东西，然后说我们认为这个或那个。对我来说，你的书的美妙之处在于，你有这些看似很小的事情，却产生了巨大的影响，因为它们是一个整体的一部分，如果我们去观察的话，它是可见的。没错。那么作为这个物种，你对此有什么结论呢？
design of the car, the internal design, the mechanics. And you know I think about that. But the point is I think that when I read your book I kept thinking about you know we Americans and maybe people all over the world and maybe because of the social media or polarization or whatever are losing the ability to think large and small Yeah, you know, we just want to give us something we can digest in six seconds or eight and say we think this That the other thing and the beauty of your book to me was you had these apparently small things that made a big difference because they were part of a whole that would be visible if we were looking. That's right. So what if you concluded about that as the species?
汽车的设计、内部设计、机械结构。你知道我一直在想这些。但关键是，当我读你的书时，我一直在想，我们美国人，或许还有全世界的人，也许是因为社交媒体、极化现象或别的什么，正在失去宏观与微观兼顾的思考能力。是的，你知道，我们只希望别人给我们一些能在六秒或八秒内消化完的东西，然后对这件事或那件事发表意见。而你的书最妙的地方在于，你写了这些表面上看起来很小却带来巨大改变的事情，因为它们是一个整体的一部分，如果我们仔细观察的话，就能看得出来。没错。那么，作为这个物种，你对此有什么结论？
Are we losing the predisposition to look to be aware? Well, I mean, I think that not being aware of all things all the time is like a brain coping mechanism. We have like 11 million stimuli coming out of it all time. So the things that don't change, we don't notice them. It's forgivable. You know, I mean, like our brains are meant to filter some of that stuff out. We're not going to be able to change. And so there's no problem with people not noticing things.
我们是不是正在失去那种去寻找、去留心观察的倾向？嗯，我的意思是，我觉得对所有事情随时随地都保持关注，其实就像是一种大脑的应对机制。我们每时每刻都要面对大约1100万个刺激信号。所以那些没有变化的事物，我们就注意不到了。这是可以理解的。你知道我的意思，就是说我们的大脑本来就是用来过滤掉其中一部分信息的。我们不可能什么都改变。所以人们没有注意到一些事情，这并没有什么问题。
I do think that what I like about these examples of ants and us and why we're resilient is because there are those people and things and entities that do think long-term, that solve problems that are, they're not really just altruistic. They're not just doing it completely selflessly. We're trying to create this thing together and it requires thought and design and differentiation. As much as I like the idea of you fixing your own break, you know, when you were a kid in your car, it was like there's also a beauty in other people doing it better, and you just kind of like trusting in that,
我确实觉得，我喜欢蚂蚁和我们这些例子的原因，以及我们为什么具有韧性，是因为总有那些人、那些事和那些实体，它们会进行长远思考，去解决那些问题——它们不完全是利他主义的。它们不只是在做完全无私的事情。我们正试图一起创造这个东西，这需要思考、设计和差异化。尽管我很喜欢那种你小时候自己修理汽车刹车的想法，但别人能把事情做得更好，而你只需去信任他们，这其中也有着一种美妙之处，
and that is becomes like how we build a society. And so the world is made up of, it has to be an ecosystem of things we know in control, and there's like individual agency and liberty and things like this. And then you have to like fall into the warm embrace of a designed world that a people have thought of and their expertise is present.
而这正是我们构建社会的方式。所以这个世界是由以下部分组成的：它必须是一个生态系统，既有我们了解和控制的事物，包含个人的自主权、自由等等；然后你又必须投入到一个经过设计的世界的温暖怀抱中，那里凝聚着人们的思考和专业知识。
And maybe you don't understand it. And hopefully we're engaged enough in a civic society that you trust those things. And I think that that's super inspiring. Like I love the things that we create together collectively. And cities are inspiring like machines that are just, they're super efficient. They, you know, like if we're talking about your own, like carbon footprint living in a city is better living on your own in these ways.
也许你并不理解它。但希望我们能足够积极地参与到公民社会中去，从而信任这些事物。我认为这超级鼓舞人心。我喜欢我们共同创造的一切。城市就像是极具效率的机器，它们非常鼓舞人心。你知道的，如果我们谈到你自己的碳足迹，从某些方面来说，住在城市里其实比独自生活更好。
And there's all these things that I think that if you take the time to notice the small details of how your life is made better by somebody thinking through a problem that you probably don't even, you know, know you need to have solved. But also just like then go just look at the Brooklyn Bridge, you know, I can just go like, wow, that thing is amazing. I mean, like when, so like in the 89th Great out here in the Bay Area, a part of the Bay Bridge collapsed and then they rebuilt the Eastern span. And it was about to open when I lived here. I didn't live here during 89, but I lived here after. So when the new span was opening up, they were going to a big day, kind of like when the opening of Brooklyn Bridge,
还有所有这些事情，我觉得如果你花时间去注意生活中的小细节——比如别人为你思考了一个你可能甚至不知道需要解决的问题，从而让你的生活变得更美好——除此之外，再去看看布鲁克林大桥，你知道的，我就会忍不住想：哇，那东西太厉害了。我的意思是，当湾区在89年发生大地震时，海湾大桥的一部分倒塌了，然后他们重建了东跨度。我住在这里的时候，它正准备开通。我在89年时不住在这里，但我之后搬来住了。所以当新桥段开通时，那将是一个盛大的日子，有点像布鲁克林大桥开通的时候，
like people were gonna walk across it, like celebrate it, and there was all these sort of problems that need to fix with the Eastern span, and so they didn't have that day where everyone walks across the beach. And I just think that was a huge, like missed opportunity of this collective enjoyment
人们会走过它、庆祝它，但东跨度有各种各样需要解决的问题，所以他们没有举行那种所有人一起步行过桥的活动。我只是觉得，这错失了一个巨大的集体享受的机会，
of these things that we can make together when a structural engineer who knows way more than you about the tensile strength of steel and, you know, like a city planner and a government body and the willing taxpayers that put money into this. And we should all just walk across this thing and marvel and it's like amazing thing, you know,. We now can get from that side to that side. Like millions of times a day. And I love that. First of all, you got ahead of me in a positive way, but I was going to acknowledge that I was so grateful I didn't have to be a mechanic. And that also, that I think being able to trust people in small and
去享受我们共同建造的这些东西。当一个对钢材抗拉强度了解远胜于你的结构工程师，以及城市规划者、政府机构和愿意出资的纳税人共同努力时，我们本该一起走过这座桥，发出赞叹，这真是一件了不起的事情，你知道的。我们现在每天可以从那一头走到这一头数百万次。我喜欢这一点。首先，你以一种积极的方式抢在了我前面，但我本来就想承认，我无比庆幸自己不用当个机械师。而且我也认为，能够以细微直接的方式去信任他人，
direct ways, and in ways that you understand, which is if you notice more like the things in your book, it's easy to do. It might lay the foundation of restoring some trust in a larger sense. And being able to forget things is very important. And I think knowing that design in the world like helps you in that way, not that you know need to know how to do it or need to know how it works, but you need to know someone thought about it, you know, it's kind of like being a parent, you know, like, like you don't need your kid to know all this I've done for you all the time. That's the water they swim in is that you love them and take care of them, you know?
并且以你能理解的方式——也就是如果你多留意一下你书里提到的那些事情，这就很容易做到——可能会为在更大范围内恢复某种信任奠定基础。能够忘记一些事情是非常重要的。而且我认为，了解世界上的设计会以这种方式对你有所帮助——并不是说你需要知道如何去做，或者需要知道它是如何运作的，而是你需要知道有人为此动过脑筋。你知道的，这有点像为人父母，你知道的，你不需要你的孩子一直都知道你为他们做了多少事。他们所呼吸的空气就是你爱他们、照顾他们，你知道的？
And so, them not recognizing the water isn't a fault on their part. They shouldn't recognize the water. They should just like swim in it. And a well-designed world that is about care and mutual benefit and all that sort of stuff is like that and super. I mean, it's why do the things I do. And you can't read this book of yours about all these genius little things and some of the things that don't work without believing that we actually are highly interdependent, we need each other and we're all better off if we just keep trying to get better and device. And sometimes the answer is not a mega solution that it affects the whole world. Sometimes it's a low cost high impact, active genius that can echo across national borders even.
所以，他们没有意识到空气的存在并不是他们的错。他们不应该去留意空气。他们应该只是在其中畅游。一个以关怀、互惠和所有这类事情为基础的精心设计的世界就是这样的，而且太棒了。我的意思是，这就是我做这些事的原因。你不可能在不相信我们实际上高度相互依存、我们需要彼此的情况下，去读这本关于所有这些天才般的小东西以及其中一些行不通的事物的小书；如果我们不断努力变得更好、不断创新，我们所有人都会过得更好。有时答案并不是一个影响全世界的超级解决方案，有时它是一个低成本、高影响力的天才之举，甚至可以在国与国之间产生共鸣。
Totally. But that's what I got out of reading your book. I thought, you know, this, oh, that's, that's so heartening because that's what I feel when we do these stories that it really is an optimistic view to sort of examine these things and realize our interdependence. And yeah, I'm so, I'm so pleat, like, we don't, we don't often, like, talk about it directly. Like, we hope you get it through the Gestalt of the show
完全同意。但这正是我从读你的书中获得的体会。我想，哦，这太令人鼓舞了，因为这就是当我制作这些故事时的感受：审视这些事情并认识到我们的相互依存，确实是一种乐观的视角。是的，我太高兴了——我们不常直接谈论这个。我们希望你能通过节目和书的整体氛围来体会到这一点，所以。
in the book, and so. Well, given the political polarization in the world and America, it's probably better that you don't talk about it directly. People come to it almost by osmosis. I think that more and more this idea of us being dependent on each other and that a world in which we're completely on our own that some people like love to imagine for themselves politically is a terrible world that we don't want at all and that these physical manifestations of us working together in the form of cities and the form of roads,
好吧，鉴于世界和美国的政治极化，你最好还是不要直接谈论它。人们几乎是通过潜移默化来理解这一点的。我认为，这种关于我们相互依存的想法，以及某些人在政治上喜欢为自己想象的那种完全依靠自己的世界——那是一个我们根本不想要的可怕世界——而这些我们共同努力的物质体现（以城市和道路的形式），
you know, people should recognize how much they depend on each other, even when they feel like they're completely alone. And it all requires, like, an idea that we have designed systems and expertise in a faith in those systems, and that no one person has to do everything that only works because we all work together on it. The built world is all that. No one person can build a building. No company can build a bridge. It takes a government. The government is the manifestation of our collective care for each other.
人们应该认识到他们是多么依赖彼此，即使在他们觉得自己完全孤立无援的时候也是如此。这一切都需要这样一种观念：我们拥有经过设计的系统和专业知识，并且对这些系统充满信心；没有人必须包办一切，这一切之所以行之有效，仅仅是因为我们都在为此共同努力。人造世界就是这一切的总和。没有人能独自建造一栋建筑。没有一家公司能建造一座大桥。这需要一个政府。政府就是我们对彼此集体关怀的体现。
I don't think that's anything to shy away from. I think that's something to celebrate, to exalt in. And it manifests, like you said, in the biggest things and it manifests in the smallest things, like little tiny things and little regulations. And there's all types of silly dumb side effects of regulations of people having good thoughts about things that have bad effects.
我认为这没什么好回避的。我认为这是值得庆祝、值得狂喜的事情。正如你所说，它体现在最大的事物中，也体现在最小的事物中，比如微小的细节和细碎的规章制度。关于那些本意良好却带来不良影响的事物，各种规章制度往往会产生各种荒谬可笑的副作用。
I mean, we have a whole section on weird architectural features that have to do with taxes. There was always a time when I was trying to figure out how to tax people, before governments to run. And basically, monarchy's to run at this point. So they would tax this, how many bricks you had in your house? They would tax how many windows you had in your house. And so then people would board up windows
我的意思是，我们有一整节专门讲述与税收有关的奇特建筑特色。一直以来，当我在试图弄清楚如何向人们征税时——在政府开始运转之前，当时基本上是由君主制运转。所以他们会这样征税：你有多少块砖？他们会根据你家里有多少扇窗户来征税。于是人们就把窗户封起来，
and they would tax how many bricks you had. So people made bigger bricks. And then they would tax in Paris, they would tax how high your roof was, how many bricks you had. So people made bigger bricks, you know, like, and then they would tax like in Paris, they'd tax like how high your roof was, you know, like, how many stories you had. And so, but they decided that it wasn't taxed past a certain line, which created that man-cert roof, that sort of man-cert roof with a dormer, which is like the Paris roof that that's created because of taxes. You know what I mean? And it's like a dumb side effect of trying to solve a problem. And then in the end, you made this beautiful roof line that we think of as quintessentially, you know, like, Parisian. And so, like, it's not that we don't make mistakes when we collectively
他们会根据你拥有多少砖块来征税。所以人们制造了更大的砖块。然后他们在巴黎征税，他们会对你的屋顶有多高、你有多少砖块征税。所以人们制造了更大的砖块，你知道的，然后他们会在巴黎征税，他们会征税你的屋顶有多高，你知道的，你有多少层楼。然后，但他们决定超过一定高度就不再征税，这就创造了那种孟莎式屋顶，那种带有老虎窗的孟莎式屋顶，就像巴黎那种因为税收而产生的屋顶。你知道我的意思吗？这就像是试图解决一个问题时产生的愚蠢副作用。到最后，你却创造出了我们认为是巴黎典型风格的漂亮屋顶线条。所以，这并不是说我们在集体决定自上而下解决问题并寻找变通方法时不会犯错。这个世界就是由这种对话组成的：善意的事物与行之有效的善意事物、失败的善意事物、以及我们找到变通方法来应对的愚蠢事物，因为人们非常擅长逃税。当他们必须这样做时，他们会想方设法地逃税。在英国，你可以通过砖块的大小来确定一座建筑的征税时期。这是一个非常奇妙的现象，值得去注意、认识和意识到，这其中既有荒谬的成分，也有一段让有趣事情发生的美好故事。
decide to solve problems on their top-down things and ways to get around it. That's what the world is made of, is that sort of conversation between well-intentioned things and well-intentioned things that work, well-intentioned things that fail, dumb things that we find ways to work around because people are great at avoiding taxes. They will do it when they have to find all kinds of ways. And you can date the period of taxation of a building because of the size of the brick in England. That's an amazing thing to notice and recognize and realize that that was part folly and also part just good story that made something like interesting happen.
并不是说我们总能集体把事情搞清楚。我们并没有。我们把事情弄得一团糟。但所有这些东西正是构成了设计的要素。这就是为什么它看起来很有趣，因为到头来它们都只是故事。如果你懂得如何去观察，这是一个迷人的世界。[♪ 背景音乐播放中...]如果你是刚刚通过国会的基建法案的负责人，你拥有这样一笔资金。
It's not that we collectively figure stuff out. We don't. We're a mess. But all that stuff is what makes design. That's why it's fun to look at, because it's all just stories in the end. And it's a fascinating world, if you just know to look at it. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in If you were the czar of the infrastructure bill that had just passed the Congress, that has, you've had this kind of money.
根据你多年来观察所有这些系统、所有这些对很多人有效或带来一些问题的经验，你认为我们现在应该优先做的事情是什么？首先，混凝土的自然寿命大约是100年。恰好我们正进入这样一个时代：WPA（公共事业振兴署）建造的所有那些美丽的东西即将达到它们的自然寿命。它们需要维护。我觉得设计报道或设计思维犯错的一个方面在于，
Based on your, now many years of experience, looking at all these systems and all these things that worked out a lot of people or that created some problems, what do you think the priority should be on what we should be doing now? First of all, the natural lifespan of concrete is, you know, like about 100 years. It just so happens that we're entering into this era where all those beautiful things at WPA built are about to reach their natural lifespan. And they require just maintenance. Like, I think that one of the ways that design, reporting or design thinking gets things wrong
你可能会想出一些伟大的解决方案来解决一个问题，然后就万事大吉了。但世界并不是这样运转的。世界要世俗得多，它更多地与维护有关，而不一定仅仅是解决方案。所以我要做的第一件事就是评估我们拥有的所有东西。
is that you can come up with some great solution and solve a problem, and then it's done. But that's not how the world works. The world is much more mundane, and it has much more to do with maintenance than solutions, necessarily. And so the first thing I would do is assess all the things that we have.
就像我们拥有这些钢筋生锈、结构摇摇欲坠的钢筋混凝土结构一样。我们应该做我所认为的——或者必须被认为是——那种枯燥的工作，也就是让我们现有的东西再多维持一百年。我知道这听我觉得我们应该开始改变观念，不再仅仅迷恋天才的问题解决者和伟大的设计创新方案，而是应该开始认识到，维护才是我们存在的原因。
It's like we have these reinforced concrete structures that have rebar that are rusting and things falling apart. And we should just do what I would consider to be, you know, or must be, what consider to be the boring work of just making the things that we have last another hundred years. I know that's not, you know, like super exciting, but I feel like that we should begin to like instead of just the genius problem solvers and solutions of great little design innovations, we should start recognizing that maintenance is a reason why we're here.
维护和关怀我们现有的东西，因为最环保的建筑就是已经建好的建筑。我们要认识到这一点，我们必须把钱花在刀刃上，让它们更持久。至于我会投入资金的另一个部分，我会做点类似于WPA的事情，就像说：我们正在制造的东西不仅要功能强大、意义重大，还要美丽动人，当你看到它时，你会为自己是一个美国人而感到骄傲，而不会因为——我不知道，因为它看起来像是个烂摊子或者太贵之类而退缩，
Maintenance and care of the things we have, because the greenest building is a building that's already built. And to recognizing that, that we just have to spend money on things and make them last longer. And the other part of it that I would spend on it is I would do kind of the WPA thing of like going this thing that we're making is not only going to be functional and important, it's going to be beautiful and you're going to be proud to be an American when you see it and not shy away from it because, I don't know, because it seems like a boondoggle or it seems like too expensive or something,
而是真正去倾心投入，你知道吗？我们建造这些东西是因为我们齐心协力。这就是美国，我们是一个理念。对我来说，这就是我想要呈现它的方式，也是我建造它的方式。是的，这就是我会做的事。在我们离开之前，首先，谢谢你说的这些。我想我相信，尽管当今世界存在着各种极化、争斗和谩骂，但如果你剥开我们中任何一个人足够深的外表，底下依然有一个活生生的人。
just like really lean into, you know what? We make those things because we do them together. And that's what America is, that we are an idea. And that, to me, is like how I would present it as much as make it. Yeah, that's how I would do it. Before we go, first of all, thank you for that. I think I believe that most people in spite of all this polarization and fighting and name calling in the world of day, if you scratch nearly any of us deep enough, there's still a person down there somewhere.
如果你剥开我们中任何一个人足够深的外表，底下依然有一个活生生的人。我们拥有最基本的母性或人类本能。我想，关于阅读你的书并看到你注意到的所有这些成千上万的事物，我认为人们注意到的其实比他们自己知道的要多，甚至比他们意识到的还要多，但有太多东西是他们不知道的，他们太忙了，不得不担心如何去维持生计，你知道的，而你帮助他们理解了这一点。所以我认为你所说的是对的。我认为任何能增强我们自信心和自我意识的事情，都会增强我们合作的意愿。并增强我们从终点倒推的能力。
If you scratch nearly any of us deep enough, there's still a person down there somewhere. And we have basic human instincts. And I think the one thing about reading your book and seeing all these zillion things that you noticed, I think people do notice more than they know, or even are aware of, but there's so much that they don't know and they're so busy they have to worry about how they're going to, you know, bring in and you help them to understand that. And so I think that what you said is right. I think anything that increases our self-confidence and our self-awareness will increase our willingness to cooperate. And increase our ability to begin with the end in mind.
我发现这是一种社会基础设施，我猜是这样的，但就像你谈到的所有这些事情一样，那些做得好的事情和没做好的事情。大多数建造任何东西的人，他们都试图把他们所做的事情做好。是的。是的。这就是我得出的结论。有时他们是对的，有时他们是错的。我的意思是，偶尔你会遇到像迈阿密那种停车场
I find that this is social infrastructure, I guess, but it's like all these things that you talk about, the things that were done well and things that weren't. Most everybody that built whatever they were building, they tried to do a good job of what they did. Yeah. Yeah. That's the conclusion I reached. And sometimes they were building, they tried to do a good job of what they did. That's the conclusion I reached, and sometimes they were right and sometimes they were wrong. I mean, once in a while you have a thing like this Miami deal where the parking decks
没有得到维护的事情。诸如此类。我认为你的维护论点非常好。也许只是因为我到了这个年纪，一切都已经建成，现在，你知道的。我认为维护是自切片面包发明以来最伟大的东西。但你给了你所有的听众
weren't maintained. All that. And I think your maintenance argument is very good. Maybe just because I've reached the age when it's all made and it's now, you know. I think maintenance is the greatest thing since sliced bread. But you have given all your listeners
和读者一份厚礼。谢谢你，普雷斯顿女士。因为我真诚地相信，了解事物能够建立自信，而在你能够萌生信任和合作之前，你必须具备一定程度的自信。我们需要在美国建立更多社会资本，具有讽刺意味的是，我们或许可以通过物质资本来最好地建立它。我同意。我同意。围绕某样东西凝聚共识很容易。那是一个巨大的物质实体，因为你知道它是真诚制造的。这是一个非常棒的认识。这是基础设施建设等伟大成就之一，比如那些获得通过的项目，对吧？
and your readers a great gift. Thank you, Miss Preston. Cause I honestly believe that knowing things builds confidence and you have to have a certain amount of self-confidence before you can entertain trust and cooperation. We need more social capital in America and ironically we might be able to best build it through physical capital. I agree. I agree. That's easy to rally around something. That's a big physical object, because you know it was made sincerely. And that's a great thing to recognize. It's one of the great things like infrastructure builds, or like the ones that get passed, right?
这是因为人们认识到，齐心协力建造东西正是造就我们人类的原因。它不仅对那些需要其他东西的人（比如改善他们的收入、获得医疗保健的渠道，或者任何有助于他们出行的帮助）有价值，而且对那些需要在当前事业中取得成功的人、那些有抱负和正在努力工作的人也有价值。我对此感觉很好。我希望去加州时能见到你。我非常乐意。
And it's because people recognize that building things together is what makes us a human. And it's valuable not only to people who need other things, like to improve their income or their access to health care or whatever helps them move around for it, but it's valuable for people who need to succeed at what they're doing now. Who are aspirational and who are working. And I feel good about it. I hope I get to see you when I'm out in California. I would love that.
告诉我一声。我太高兴了。我在那边有一些古怪的朋友，我们很乐意邀请你共进晚餐。我可以对你进行拷问，坐在我旁边。好吧，一言为定。一言为定。如果你愿意接受拷问，我来买单。听起来太棒了。
Let me know. I love that. I have some zany friends out there that we would love to have you at dinner. Like I could grill you and sit on me. Well, it's a deal. You got a deal. I'll pay for the meal if you'll be grilled. That sounds delightful.
好的。非常感谢。谢谢你。为什么我要告诉你这些？这是由iHeart Radio、克林顿基金会和at Will Media联合制作的。我们的执行制片人是Craig Manassian和Will Monati。我们的制作团队包括Jameson Katsufas、Tom Galtons、Sarah Horowitz和Jake Young，并得到了Liz Rattory和Josh Pharnam的制作支持，原创音乐由Wat White创作。特别感谢John
Okay. Thank you so much. Thank you. Why am I telling you this? Is a production of I Heart Radio, the Clinton Foundation, and at Will Media. Our executive producers are Craig Manassian and Will Monati. Our production team includes Jameson Katsufas, Tom Galtons, Sarah Horowitz, and Jake Young, with production support from Liz Rattory and Josh Pharnam, original music by Wat White. Special thanks to John
Sykes、John Davidson、on Hellerina、Corey Gansley、Kevin Thurm、Oscar Flores，以及我们在克林顿基金会的所有敬业员工和合作伙伴。感谢克林顿总统邀请我上节目，并对我和我的《99%隐形城市》以及一笔冷饭资金表现出如此真诚的兴趣。如果你喜欢这次谈话，我强烈建议你收听并订阅《为什么我要告诉你这些》。这个人真懂得如何进行对话。如果你想深入了解其中某集，有一集叫《建筑如何拯救生命》，由我的英雄Michael Murphy主讲，绝对是不容错过的精彩内容。《99%隐形公司》由我Roman Mars、Delaney Hall、Swan Rial、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Le、Chris Baroupe、Emmett Fitzgerald、Martín Gonzales、Joe Rosenberg、Jason De Leon、Lashamadon、Jacob Maldonado Medina、Sophia Klatsker共同制作。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于奥克兰美丽的住宅区、潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，也可以在@99PI org上@节目组。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也都有账号。
Sykes, John Davidson, on Hellerina, Corey Gansley, Kevin Thurm, Oscar Flores, and all our dedicated staff and partners at the Clinton Foundation. Thank you to President Clinton for having me on and for taking such genuine interest in the 99% of visible city by me and for a cold stead. If you dug this conversation, I really recommend you listen and subscribe to why I'm telling you this. This man knows how to have a conversation. If you're looking for one particular to dive into, the episode called How Architecture
你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，以及99PI过去的每一集节目。我是Roman Mars，在米德尔敦山二楼一个非常安静的宴会厅为您报道。您收听的是来自Sirius XM的Stitcherittra播客。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Can Save Lives featuring Michael Murphy, who's a hero of mine, and one of the crackerjack get on it. 99% Invisible is Kurt Coles to Delaney Hall, Swan Rial, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Le, Chris Baroupe, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martín Gonzales, Joe Rosenberg, Jason De Leon, Lashamadon, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too.
能拯救生命》，嘉宾是迈克尔·墨菲，他是我的偶像，也是顶尖高手之一。《99% Invisible》的成员包括柯特·科尔斯、德兰妮·霍尔、斯旺·里亚尔、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·勒、克里斯·巴鲁普、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、马丁·冈萨雷斯、乔·罗森伯格、杰森·德莱昂、拉沙马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于奥克兰美丽的住宅区潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。您可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @我（Roman Mars）以及节目（99PI org）。我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有账号。
You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. This is Roman Mars reporting from a very quiet ballroom on the second floor of Midtown Hill. You're listening to a Stitcherittra Podcast, from Sirius XM. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及《99PI》过去的每一集节目。我是罗曼·马尔斯，在中城山二楼一个非常安静的宴会厅为您报道。您收听的是来自 Sirius XM 的 Stitcherittra 播客。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。